c'est un travail de moine
chaque montre est fabriqué à la main
boîtier au mécanisme
avec une minuscule pièce pas plus grosse
qu'une miette c'est un savoir faire qui
se perd mais xavier giraud des le
cultive avec passion
là on allait lui des limites qui va
directement fixé dessus
il est horloger à la manufacture
raquette à en russie un fleuron du nom
soviétique un équipement comme il n'en
existe plus une entreprise russe kaki
sauver de la faillite il ya dix ans par
l'entrepreneur français david henderson
sûr on est très fiers d'avoir contribué
à sauvegarder leur loge rue ce qui
autrement auraient
auraient disparu vous aviez et est ici
dans l'atelier à saint pétersbourg quand
notre dame de paris a brûlé en 2019 une
fois passée l'émotion sur moment de fête
que la l'édifice était gravement
atteints on ne sait ni mais en fait une
pendule entièrement mécanique qui
sonnait les cars et les heures depuis
1867 à paris
les artisans russes veulent t'aider et
organise une cagnotte pour soutenir
leurs collègues de paris sauf que la
perte est totale donc il ne reste plus
rien et la deuxième tragédie c'est qu'il
n'y a pas de plan les plans d'époque
n'ont pas été conservé l'espoir de la
reconstruire à l'identique renaît deux
mois plus tard quand cette horloge
presque jumelle à celle de notre dame et
découverte cachée dans une autre église
la sainte trinité du 9e arrondissement
une fois que cet ouvrage était retrouvée
ça nous a servi de base pour nous après
comprendre
et coordonnée avec paris les travaux de
saint pétersbourg à paris où une
association a été mise sur pied pour
sauver la pendule des horlogers
planification sur la base de ces plans
3d nous actuellement on va on va
fabriquer là la partie ce qui s'appelle
leur logement l'horloge de contrôle
pardon voilà concrètement on va
travailler là-dessus une tâche colossale
qui doit se faire à distance en raison
de la pandémie
l'ingénieur artyom smirnov passe des
heures à étudier les plans afin de
déterminer quelle pièce raketa pourra
reproduire en série comme les vestes et
les boucles sierra keita se spécialise
dans les petites pièces l'entreprise a
déjà à son actif la plus grande horloge
mécanique du monde celle du magasin de
jouets dette ce qui me rend moscou un
des joyaux de la capitale russe là vous
regardez le plus grand mouvement
mécanique du monde
c'est énorme la construction d'un
mouvement mécanique qu'il soit comme ça
où comme ça les principes fondamentaux
restent les mêmes ça occupe et serait ce
que travailler là dessus c'est quand
même un honneur et sa cristallise les
émotions ont certes mais ça ne signe ça
nous rassemble est amplement le projet
n'en est qu'à ses débuts et devra être
approuvé par les bâtiments de france
mais il n'ya aucun doute ici qu'il y
aura un peu de la russie dans le
chantier du siècle qui la restauration
de notre dame de paris
et c'est un pont qui est très bon entre
des russes des français grâce à
l'horlogerie parce que pour les
horlogers je crois cette horloge simple
lame
le corps de notre dame elle avance
toujours elle mesure le temps qui passe
et donc symboliquement c'est très très
fort
la résurrection prendra des années
mais en tant qu horloge ils ont
l'habitude le temps c'est leur
spécialité et personne n'en connaît
autant la valeur ici tamar alter escaut
radio-canada saint pétersbourg